so Elliot here tonight for spike Islands
how excited are you to be nominated the
British Independent Film Awards I think
it's amazing I mean I never never
thought I'd be I'd be SLA or even this
position and judged by caring so much I
was fighting for that it's pushed me
this way
so yeah you're looking a little bit
different tonight than he did in the
film aren't you well I've got me a
Vermeer cool yeah well I was really
upset about it because and after we
finished filming lecturers left my hair
to grow in it that's not what I mean it
got to it got to about this long and
that's a quote for a jump in the cloud
but our projects understood so a small
part but it was a I felt like it was a
tricky part anyway that's get it cook
for that has been good yeah it's about
that stuff I think I've still got the
hair home even our approach that you've
been working on mm yeah it's been a
young young guy young like called
called Connery's 40 and he's he's just
been affinity sort of like him not
street cast book because by the halberds
and they they found this lad from from
Bradford we did a short film we've not
long before actually and a sort and no
word of like ridiculously good actor and
I just am just really pleased to work
with him and I thought the scenes that
we had to get back to place I would
approver and I feel like they went
really well
and everyone seems to be saying good
stuff about wait so yeah just how it
goes and Clare was lovely as well so how
do you feel mom a bit is wearing one
away today on whatever is the audition
on Sat then dim Amy would reserve in
gameplay I was then I don't know if at
like because audition in front of mommy
she just had lovely the dice it was the
night it did that refreshing go around
this is not what else you been up to
since then hey relax [ __ ] and that's
about it no that's it keeping hell fair
peddling me bike about and I said you
deserve a bit of a rest even busier than
you what would you like to be up to next
oh that's a good question that actually
I'd like to Sevilla test tested tested
made fire a German accent was concerned
because I think that
well Fiona the produced by currencies I
think I've got a really good ear for
accents I don't know I just there I like
messing about I always mess em up when
I'm at home I bet even realizing doing
it half the time going to Scottish and
Irish give me the sample going no I'd
listen that dad because they've been
boys myself with no way of doing that no
way
so TV fill-in there's nothing the
pipeline at the moment I mean I'm just
waiting for this for food spike alland
and then the club and our project so
it's obvious Giants come out so I'm just
just waiting and that realer I'd like to
I'm trying to think what I'd like to do
at the slight tuck and and anything
which is in which should get my safe in
something great if they were as far as
the characters concerned is what I'd
like to do next
I mean I've got in China not warmer but
about to improve I'd really like to work
with as well
so anything that so that's that's that's
one thing I'd really like to do and
these are maybe a little bit like Luke
and Harry's red wires yeah brother Scott
Lucas Melaleuca no it's it's our liking
it I like the ring we already got my
girlfriend knows and Luke and hurries
well on a thing I've I've met I've met
them both in the past on like one or two
occasions I think that my captors can
they were capable there's gotta be
reform sax wins okay sure
you